hi guys yeah right so how are you
fantastic I mean all things considered
but the gang's all here I love it
now we pulled it off somehow it happens
Katie I yeah are you still in the
sanitizer outfit or did you change
Hey I felt pleased you look so cute yeah
we're doing a quarantine zoom from three
different locations how much have you
guys stayed in touch while stuck at home
hey do you want to take the lead on that
yeah I think we can all speak to this
but we have a little sidebar chat that
we check in with each other
I remember we remember actually Lionel
telling us you know if the apocalypse if
the apocalypse ever happens and this was
like a couple seasons ago just meet at
my house special place and so early on
14 times I checked in with Lila he's
still good for that I mean we're all
we've all been blessed to meet very kind
of important people that can give us
amazing info and if I had some info that
I thought you know like you need to hear
to get ready you know to as far as
traveling I mean we were never we were
just doing it as friends we were just
like you know we're hearing that the
country may shut down in three days and
and so we were kind of looking out for
each other looking after each other's
families like like friends do Katie told
me to go buy all the toilet paper paper
Nationalists go to Kroger get anything
like that she's doing a polar paper
shortage but you know you know what's so
what's so wonderful though I think the
bottom line is that we actually do like
each other
I mean that's that may sound like
yeah but but when I say that I really
must say that we do cover each other's
back because remember when we first
started we didn't we didn't have the
team thing because we didn't know what
it was like so the first season it took
us to kind of get used to it after that
once I realized what I had between the
two of them oh my god the rest was off
to the races I mean it's been a it's
been a good marriage it's it truly is it
so special and it still resonates even
at this you know this phase of American
Idol when you guys are going into these
at home episodes it was beautiful to see
the camaraderie still resonate between
y'all and now your family is growing cuz
hey look we are all having to juggle
working from home so how are you
juggling you know judging is the idol
performances without your fellow judges
this judges by you and then also
prepping for your first child um you
know actually this time has brought in a
lot of balance probably necessary
balance it's it's slow what was that
word what was that right baby oh I
haven't heard what it's actually good
need to prep this kind of mindset
because even after quarantine is done
and everyone goes out and celebrates all
be probably still at home making sure
everyone's like drinking during
quarantine and I'm like not now Luke
margarita - margarita three margaritas
shot for you girlfriend I mean that's
the thing it's like you know it's it's
interesting there's a lot to think of
but I have found a lot of ways to be
incredibly grateful and to bond family
on a on like on a on a on a deeper level
than I ever have I think you know rather
than just like a vacation or a holiday
there's some there's some there's a new
foundation that is being laid within
families between you know partners and
I just think people that are quarantined
together there's the will never forget
this fun just shocking yourself out of
your routine is yeah very tricky I mean
you get so used to however you rolls and
and with me you know Caroline had her
you know she had her morning coffee at
this time and this time and this time
and this time and I but you know as but
now what I've been now you gotta share
the space well what's interesting is to
know that no you can deal with it you
know you can change up some stuff in
your life you can have drastic changes
and and cope with it and I'm sure a lot
of you know I'm I mean I'm not I'm sure
a lot of people out there going well you
know I got dealt an interesting
situation and I've made the most of it
it was tricky in the beginning but now
this is the norm and you know I think
our new norms will change forever I
think you you know I think in five or
ten years when you hear this right new
little flu bug or something like that
will will pay attention a lot more you
know I mean see you so we're all we're
all learning as we go and yeah this for
me I must tell you this has been a
sobering moment because you know my
friends you know the joke with all of my
friends used to be very simple if I ever
said to you I'll call you back
don't look for the phone call I'm never
gonna call you back but what's happening
now is I'm calling my friends back to
find out are you okay is everything okay
everybody's solid and it's a sobering
time because I'm just so grateful that
we and I've always watched it and heard
about it when you had other entertainers
put on shows during the war or doing a
you know a tragedy that happened in
America and I would always think you
know how good it must have felt to be
Bob Hope back then when that was
happening and all of a sudden now we are
actually
performing at a time when people need to
be uplifted and I just feel so blessed
with my my fellow judges to be able to
do bring some joy somewhere brought us
these are tough times and I must tell
you the first responders I just can't
tell you how great they are and have to
be what else to be doing what we're
doing and uplifting these kids and also
uplifting America I'm very proud of what
we're doing
[Music]